why was
kong on skull island why did his parents
and the rest of his kind even leave the
hollow earth
to live in a small island in the middle
of the pacific ocean
well in this video we will tell you the
exact reasons why
and it is connected with the events of
the titan war
and the hollow earth this is confirmed
to be official
and it is taken from information given
to us
in the novelization of godzilla vs com
and the comics kingdom come as well as
godzilla dominion
and the birth of gong comics that are
all a part of a connected universe
but before we head into the video do
subscribe to be a part of mind cue
family
so let's get this thing started so
kong is the last surviving member of a
giant titan eight population native to
skull island
which monarch member william randa
describes as an emergent stage
for massive unidentified terrestrial
organisms
or mutos kong's species successfully
drove the skullcrawlers underground
but all of them except for comb himself
was killed
skull island the birth of gong the
official prequel comments to kong skull
island the movie
features in-depth flashbacks of kong's
ancestors and
kong's birth kong species had been
living on skull island for hundreds or
even thousands of years
and were mortal rivals of the skull
crawlers according to the glimpses into
the past
but how did they come to the island from
the hollow earth
and what even led them into exile
in the movie during the story after
leads them to the hollow earth
gong's genetic memory finally leads them
to his home
kong and the humans come across a
massive temple dedicated to kong's
people
similar to the hall of kings but for
colossal apes
within a huge chamber of rams and
archways
surrounding a gigantic throne a ring of
distinctly technological pillars was
found
and there was also various artwork and
also a statue
in it there is a semi-complex puzzle
made of axes and other tools made of
godzilla scales surrounding the throne
and this fires up an ancient energy
source kong senses that he's finally
home
and thanks to a combination of instinct
and the fact that this is the first
chair of his size he's ever seen
so here we see that kong's origins is in
the hollow earth
and there was a battle even in the
throne room oh well
which led them to vacating the place
this ancient titan war and rivalry had
been teased in previous movies set in
the monster verse
teasing the battle that was always going
to be inevitable
both monsters are alphas and kings and
neither will be willing to bow down to
the other
holding to the same instincts and desire
for dominance as their apparent
predecessors once did
it's been revealed in prior
monsterville's films that neither
godzilla nor
kong are unique creatures instead they
are both the last titans standing of
their kind of their respective species
likewise myths and legends have
persisted that confirmed that their
two races were battling it out for
dominance long before modern mankind
ever came into being
but the eevee and their ancestors have a
unique story
and lore about what happened as they
both came from the place
so in the novelization of godzilla vs
kong
there was a conversation between eileen
andrews and the little girl gia
regarding kong and their history there
was an ancient painting that depicted a
humanoid creature
but with a reptilian face and a long
tail as well as sticks on the back
jiha commented that there is a story
about such a creature
in ew myths while eileen andrews
was more skeptical about it about the
fact that this up might
be a depiction of godzilla jia told a
story that referenced the ancient titan
war
and a species of kongs and godzillas
although she was
deaf she could still tell the tale
passed down
by her people for thousands of years
through sign language and also spelling
out true
phonetically like lip reading but
spelling it out
and it all revolves around an ancient
eternal enemy
which they call zozla halawa which means
bad lizard
so the story goes like this zouzla
halawa
he lived in the long ago below like gong
like us he ate a star here and it made
him evil
he could throw rays of the star out of
his mouth
and burn things so it was decided that
he could no longer live in the long ago
below
evie and kong made born of friendship
become one people to fight
zozla halawa they fought for a long time
trying to make him leave something went
wrong
i think someone broke a taboo maybe
anyway kong and evie people traveled
together in darkness
until we reached the light of this place
we left
all the bad people behind and the zones
la halwa with his stomach
star too there was peace for a while but
some monsters followed us
the skull crawlers and some others
corn's parents fought them
so did gong so in this paragraph
taken from the novelization we can
clearly see it was
referring to the ancient war between
kongs and gojiras
so godzilla must have consumed something
that gave him powers
the atomic breath which was termed as
shooting rays of the star from his mouth
and due to the newfound powers godzilla
might have become
the alpha titan and began his climb to
the top of the food chain
the kongs who were the rulers beneath
the hollow earth along with the eevee
people who most
definitely had more technology back then
than in the diminishing population of
skull island
they then declared war on godzilla in
order to stop his rampage
but it did not end well for both species
and kongs
then were exiled along with the ewe to
skull island
and left the other humans that sided
with godzilla behind as well as the
skull crawlers
inside the hollow earth so let's go to
godzilla dominion in the comics
the tie in comments to godzilla versus
skull kind of like a prequel to the
action movie
the big g had to save quite a number of
titans from other titans as well as
from humans and also fought others to
establish his dominance
but at the end after fighting titanos
diamond
he went to his new spot to rest and feed
off of the radiation there
godzilla ventured deeper into the
caverns where he comes across one of his
old layers
which was a favorite spot of his let's
say that
which had portraits of him and his
worshipers adorning the walls
however something is different his
opponent on the other hand was not the
same
there was another here before tiamat
godzilla seized the skull
of a member of kong's species and
recognizes it as
belonging to his rival which means the
ancient rivalry
never ended and godzilla was still
searching for the comms
so in kingdom come however under a tie
in comics there was a vortex
deep inside a cave that was that was
miles from the surface
and kind of like the same one we see in
the movie when the group
along with kong were traveling to the
hollow earth but the entry to this
vortex had been
shut off for a long time which means
that it was done
purposely in order to keep godzilla from
hunting them down
in skull island and yes even the
perpetual storm did the same
keeping godzilla away from the island
but ever since camazotz came out and
created havoc on the island
and merging of the two storms the
situation got worse
and the only solution was to take the
big ape back to the hollow earth
[Music]
you